i had a a conversation with a security
company uh protection like executive
security company and these guys are very
very good at what they do want the best
of the marketplace
and they'll they'll hire a navy seal or
former navy seal or a you know former
delta or whoever it is to work with the
price points change depending on
uh the individual's experience but one
of the services they offered is say
say eight people at one point give you
that threat hypothetically say eight
people said you know what we're gonna do
this and we're gonna do that they have
software technology to track where that
person is going to be traveling
this is working directly with the
government now it's a fee it's not cheap
it's a lot of money you spend with them
but that is of high value for somebody
who is out there in this public figure
to say
i got these seven people who said xyz
now i know when they're in you know
landing in fort lauderdale a little bit
increasing of protection hey these next
weeks that guys over here so i can see
value in that
i i keep going back on thinking what the
next level of what you're doing today
will be there's always a next level what
you do what you're doing right now if
somebody looks at and say okay this
makes sense where you're taking you know
where you're at by the way out of your 3
100 agencies that you work in are all of
them us and canada only
uh the mainly us um and then got it yeah
yeah is there any other countries that
are with you now or is it just us and
canada it's u.s no canada okay ukraine
um and that's all we have to announce on
other countries got it so uh so
you you can do you have a bylaw or a um
uh like uh like a
commitment to the uh audience that these
are multiple countries that we will not
do business with are there any countries
that you wouldn't take any check from
them to do business with you absolutely
and i've said this before publicly you
know china russia any countries that are
adverse united states um you know we're
open to selling it to any kind of
democratically run country because our
software is built with that in mind
right these after the fact
investigations is very suited towards uh
democratic kind of countries and that
kind of judicial process iran would be
out of it yeah anything that's
sanctioned or partially sanctioned by
the us uh we we wouldn't do and so yeah
got it so you said russia china iran
you probably add north korea to that
list as well and a few other
countries that are out there that's a
those are all definite no's right so
would would the u.s government have any
problem with what you're doing
would they at all say something like you
know what clearview ai
um
you know you're you're small when you
had 10 employees you had a technology
we're doing it's awesome you guys had a
you know billion images two million
images yeah 20 billion images you're now
helping governments like ukraine you're
not helping xyz type of organizations
you're the only one in the world it's
not like there's 50 of you out there
you're the only one in the world that's
doing what they're doing don't you think
that whole only one in the world kind of
scares the crap out of the government
that has no control over some company
that's the only one in the world where
time magazine calls it the top 100
influential companies out there
yeah well they're a customer right so we
always collaborate with them on at the
state level though not at the federal
federal at the federal level fbi
homeland security et cetera da's also
with you guys yeah there's a lot of uh
you know uh federal agencies who use it
for you know crimes the government's
really big there's different arms of the
government you have congress you have
president you have the white house then
you have these agencies and you have all
that kind of stuff so
we have a lot of support
within the u.s government the government
accountability office came out with a
report on
all facial recognition used in the
federal government guidelines on how to
procure it responsibly right how to use
it what kind of use cases all that kind
of stuff so we've seen adoption there
and
and we we really honor to help out if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]